all right let's move on to Bill Cosby's
day of reckoning five months after he
was found guilty on three felony counts
of aggravated indecent assault the man
once known as America's TV dad was taken
into custody
Cosby sentence three to ten years behind
bars the 81 year old former TV star
remained silent led away in handcuffs as
he was taken into custody
just hours after he entered the
Pennsylvania courtroom once again
without wife of 54 years Camille Cosby
was convicted in April of drugging and
sexually assaulting former Temple
University women's basketball coach
andrea constand in 2004 but more than 60
women had accused Cosby of sexual
misconduct which he has denied
absolutely victorious today today was
especially emotional for former
supermodel Janice Dickinson who hugged a
smiling constant leaving the courtroom
inside Janice at arm and arm with other
accusers and at times whose fist pumping
today Cosby was also designated a
sexually violent predator he will
undergo mandatory lifetime counseling
and must register as a sex offender but
as for his Walk of Fame star we've
learned that staying put the Hollywood
Chamber of Commerce telling et quote the
stars only commemorate the recipients
professional accomplishment
[Music]
[Applause]